première jambe ces centres
catherine bergeron fondatrice et je
respecte ça
à mon goût
mais oui ici pour faire un atelier vous
à gré avec les jeunes ce parti fait par
notre projet d'insertion
socioprofessionnelle avec l'organisme
qui s'appelle le sextant
[Musique]
la mission de l'organisme qui est
d'aider les jeunes à s'orienter à donner
un cap dans leur vie personnelle
professionnelle univers du bateau c'est
un médium qui comme extraordinaire pour
transformer les gens les faire
travailler en équipe
travailler sur soi développer des
habiletés sociales comme la
communication et la gestion des émotions
le leadership gestion de la colère
l'anxiété aussi
[Musique]
il embarque source de grands voiliers
leur s'appelle le rara avis ce qui veut
dire un oiseau rare trouve ça beau parce
que tous nos jeunes sont comme deux
oiseaux rares on embarque sur ce grand
voilier l'heure pour une transatlantique
de 44 jours en mer donc des enfants la
guadeloupe jusqu'en france
[Musique]
chacun a son parcours de vie en
accueillant qui sort d'une problématique
de dépendance des toxicomanies d'autres
et on peut l'être en primant table ou
juste des gens un peu plus marginaux
une autre vie avant j'étais chanteuse
d'opéra j'ai fait de la musique pendant
dix ans j'ai fait misé dessus de là
dedans j'ai une vie professionnelle là
dedans et puis c'était difficile de
gagner ma croûte
devait toujours travaillé un peu j'ai eu
millions d'emplois dans ma vie ensuite
ça m'a vraiment appris à bûcher a
persévéré puis à croire en mes rêves
s'ils vendent pas fort on va avoir le
maximum de puissance par rapport au
rendement je suis retournée aux études à
29 en faire un bac en service social
c'est la deuxième année de mon parcours
en travail social que j'ai commencé à
faire de la voile c'est l'autre j'ai eu
d'éclaircie et le sentez en fait elle se
doutait
garde un pied dans l'univers musical en
enseignant le champ à jénine dimanche
j'ai dit que j'étais bien
on accueille les jeunes qui viennent de
quartiers les femmes on utilise la
musique comme développement pour farid
et réussit à des jeux et j'ai traversé
la salle je peux m'arrêter là
je mets